this guy is good he's always in uh
postseason for me he's woody paige
around the horn panel sports columnist
who uh joins us uh good morning woody
how is morale in denver
i think people are in a moment
in morning of morning because they felt
like uh
that the nuggets could come back and
make this more of a series
last night and i heard what you were
saying about
what the nuggets did last night but i i
think they've
gained the respect of a the lakers
[Music]
lebron james specifically and
a nation of the nba because
people before thought you know it's a
cute little tea
and that's kind of what they've been you
know they're young and they're cute and
they
they have resilience and they come back
and
yeah they're gonna get up against the
lakers and just get blown out and
they've proven that
this is a team that is not going to win
this year but
next year people go to say oh and this
could be a destination dan
that people in the past didn't want to
go to places like milwaukee
or denver or utah and i think that
when you uh have a showing like you do
in the in the playoffs
that uh people going yeah that's a team
i'd like to join
so i i think that's good for the nba
if you'd had a miami heat dimmer nuggets
nba finals the the ratings
which is so important to the nba
wouldn't wouldn't be
certainly as high as the lakers in the
celtics
but uh i think both the miami heat and
the denver nuggets uh
have proven that they can play with the
big boys what did you make of frank
vogel sort of lobbying for more free
throws
in particular i thought that was real
crap
okay you're the lakers so you got to go
groveling to the nba
for a guy that is one of the two or
three greatest players of all time
he needs to get to the free-throw line
well it worked and so
mike malone after last night's game said
you know we're going through the proper
channels
and have them look at our film now so
i think the series uh is not over
i think the nuggets could win another
game uh it's going to require and you're
talking about
joking but yokets really needs to come
out and play and not get in foul trouble
as he has twice in this series
yeah those uh that fourth and fifth foul
that that changed
the the series or changed the game i
think and then lebron saying he wanted
to guard jamal murray down the stretch
as well
was uh was kind of interesting but jamal
murray
i think uh he and a couple members of
the miami heat those are the guys that
the bubble has really been beneficial to
them devin booker we shouldn't be
surprised i mean the guy scored 70
points in the game so
but jamal what is it about jamal murray
if you were going to describe his style
for somebody who hadn't seen him woody
how would you describe it yeah 23 years
old from canada
i would just say the best uh guard from
canada since steve nash
because how many canadian guards are
there really in the world
but uh the thing about it is
people tend to forget that he's 6'4 he
looks like he's smaller
people tend to think of point guards now
six one but
he's got speed he's got size and he's
got toughness
you saw what happened when he went to
the basket late in the game and
he didn't get a call whatsoever and and
i think you know me
well enough that i'm not a homer but i'm
thinking my goodness
the the the uh the lakers begged
for lebron to get to the free-throw line
and he did why didn't they just start
the game and say lebron you get
10 free throws in a row and then we'll
start the game
and now we can move on with it but uh
joking
doesn't go the line murray doesn't go
the line but describe him as a guy and
you talked about it
the bubble has been the best thing in
the world that's ever happened to him
because people discovered that there's a
guy out there
that actually can play this game and
play it extremely well because he has
the ability to shoot the three-pointer
64 in the playoffs that he that he's got
a mid-range jumper which has disappeared
in the nba
he's got a great mid-range jumper and he
goes to the basket
and we saw a move last night that's
michael jordan
asked when he went to the basket and
that
that would be one of the two or three
best plays we've seen i mean they've
been
last second shots that have won games
but that was
maybe the best uh
around the basket play that we've seen
throughout the entire playoffs
i think he's been discovered it's like
columbus discovering america
hello there are people that live here in
america
but people have discovered a guy that
actually existed for
for three years that was playing like
that particularly early in the playoffs
when he scored 50.
when did the nug where did the nuggets
stand with the other
like the broncos avalanche rockies
nuggets what's the pecking order there
in denver a third
until last two weeks
the broncos will always be number one
the nfl is the number one game
uh the rockies who haven't really
accomplished much
four game world series against red sox
in 2007
but the rockies and then the nuggets and
then the avalanche and oddly enough the
avalanche won two stanley cups and
really
uh were positioned to win another
stanley cup this year
but i think that uh the city of dimmer
is in good shape
in regard to you know people following
the teams the broncos suck
this year and uh wait you've given up on
the broncos already
yes okay
how long do you have to wait dad i i
usually wait till mid season woody
no i i you know as a as a sports
columnist for most of my life and
and you know being on the espn whatever
it is i do there
but uh yeah see uh joking is the
joker i'm known in denver as the clown
so
that's always been my reputation but you
need to get out in front of these things
dan
you know that from your career oh you
gotta have a hot take this is your hot
take so
after week two the the uh broncos sunk
yeah it's a real possibility if they
lose to the bucks and brady this year
this weekend they go to the jets next
thursday night
adam gase if he doesn't beat the broncos
he's gone
he's fired so i i think they've got the
chiefs coming up twice we've heard of
them
they've got uh a trip to new england and
we've seen what the patriots are doing
with cam newton
they've got uh drew brees and the saints
coming to town
soon this is a team that's probably
going to be at mid-season
when they have their bye week they'll
probably be one and six
two and five something like that so i
yes i've already written them all but
that's what i do i write and i write off
you're gonna sign off now as we say
goodbye uh woody great to see you
when uh when are you back on around the
horn uh today
about uh 45 minutes but uh just for the
world uh
we're going back into our studios i've
been stuck in here like the amount of
the count of monte cristo for six months
and we're going back in the studios next
week so
we'll be back to where we were with four
panelists and tony reali and
his uh conan o'brien hair well i was
going to say your hair looks better than
tony's but then
most people's hair looks better than
tony that's right and i think i'm i'm
doing well for a man that's 104 years
old
i look good for somebody who's under
four actually i'm 74 so
i'll go with that keep stirring it up
woody great to talk to you as always
thank you
say hello to the guys for me i will
woody page espn around the horn
he's 104.